good afternoon thank you so much for
joining us at four o'clock on this
monday i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian costa as we begin with team
coverage
that weekend storm brought some major
damage to several areas across the
valley strong wind gusts
were the main factor ted florento
standing by in the weather center but
first
we're heading out to sally jaramillo
live at the west wind drive-in theater
and sally there's still a mess out there
right
yes christian as you can see behind me
strong gusts
up to 72 miles per hour was the culprit
for the damage of the screen
now staff says they are looking to
rebuild from scratch
saturday storm was a very scary
situation for many
strong gusts blowing dust rain and even
hail
was seen in many areas causing trees
signs and carports
to fall down misha nav is the owner of
vegas tree services
he has been in service for eight years
and says they were getting many phone
calls for mostly trees being on houses
pools
and even neighbors yards about
30 calls per hour and
from there we mobilize all the crews put
everybody on
overtime night work anything that we
could do to help people
anab says they're still getting calls
today and are booked until friday
other businesses like woody's arbor tree
service have also been slammed
and some businesses have scheduled a day
off for president's day
now here live as for this drive-in
theater they have been getting calls all
day
and they're looking to start the cleanup
process as early as tomorrow morning
they do want to let everybody know
that their location is still open
reporting live sally jaramillo 8 news
now
thank you sally our team coverage
continues with chief meteorologist ted
florento ted
that wind was something over the weekend
more wind coming too right
yeah we're tracking winds for tomorrow
now it won't be as strong
as what we had yesterday that is the
good news a live look outside right now
clouds mixed in with some sunshine i
want to talk more about those gusts
though and here's the timing of this too
of those gusts and we're also going to
post this on social media for you too
where sally was at north las vegas at
the airport they reported a gust of 72
miles per hour
a category 1 hurricane has winds at 74
to 95 miles per hour look at that right
up there close to a category one
hurricane mccarran
henderson southern highlands in the 60s
to high 40s for southern highlands
it was just a mess with those winds now
that wasn't from front
that was from thunderstorms a
thunderstorm that was tracking from
indian springs
all the way down through henderson
currently outside 63 degrees your 24
hour chain six degrees warmer than we
were yesterday
we have a bit of a breeze outside i'm
going to put this out on social media
too
every state in the u.s including
hawaii and alaska is under a weather
alert every single state that is rare so
rare
we're also watching the next system
that's going to bring us the winds for
tomorrow i'm going to give you the
timing of when those winds will start
how strong they'll get
and when we'll see those winds die down
that's all straight ahead in your most
accurate forecast just a few minutes
away do not miss it
christian over to you thank you ted well